this was the hardest part about playing
this character um the hardest part was
the recreations as far as the filming
goes you know because it was like some
scenes that you had to duplicate that
you could go back and see like people
going to go arrest is that the gym scene
hold on let me see how accurate he got
that down or you know the what you did
very well my dad oh thank you I
appreciate that yeah Oh what about the
social nuances and takes that yet um I
just did a whole lot of research on it
don't say I think that it was important
to just get those down as good as
possibly you know and that I researched
that for good Wow can you do too much
research at some point you just have to
tap out and say okay I've done enough
I'm ready to do enough I think I may
have got to that point where I what I
did once it was I didn't necessarily
every day to pot to pot all day on you
know sanog after like you know a shooter
scene unless it was the scene that I had
to you know reenact but I think once I
got there I was like okay I'm confident
and what I've learned and what I what
I've been able to come out
get over with my acting coaching I'm
saying just the confidence that I've
gained and I'm like I'm ready you know
saying and let's make a happen if you
have people been telling you a whole
life you look kind of like to [ __ ] do
you very much is high school for real
yeah so this is like a perfect meshing
of like it's crazy Alex coming full
circle you know I never really actually
imagined that this would be really
looking up even within this whole
process man there's still a moment to
take in and it's it's still unbelievable
what about the pressures I mean because
a lot of the characters you look you
like sugar and Snoop and these guys are
like still alive you know so what about
the pressures that come with playing a
role of this nature when there's people
who are around him still there do you
feel that at all um I did at some point
but I've gotten past that because of the
reception of these people who live with
him and walked with him and they've seen
a movie
and what they have to say about it I
mean it is beyond what I could have
imagined
so for that I'm just like humbled and
grateful and like you know I'm on cloud
nine
now you've been immersed in the world
what are your opinions on the conspiracy
theories about first of all whether or
not he's still alive you know what I was
out with that one is out you know oh
yeah I for the people that's close to
Tennessee family you know they don't
play with those conspiracy theories they
don't entertaining so you know it's
pretty much what it is um favorite Tupac
song or not Eliza me dear mama dear mama
why I want in particular because of just
how it resonates with you when you hear
it it makes you feel you know it always
brings out feeling in your mom right you
when you hear that song it just feels so
good you always like you can replace a
memory of your mom you know